there are growing calls us wanting to
crack down on the delivery of illegal
opioids by international mail US Customs
and Border Protection seized more than
180 pounds of fentanyl last year and
that's a new record but a newly released
Senate report says that's only a
fraction of what may be arriving in this
country it found that the volume of
international mail is more than doubled
in recent years overwhelming the
screeners Tonie to cope will talk to
Ohio senator Rob Portman about what
authorities must do to keep up Tony good
morning good morning like most
Republicans senator Portman supports
president Trump's push for a border wall
but after seeing how easy it can be to
order and receive illegal opioids he
thinks the better place to make a stand
against opioids is the mailbox
we need the wall for stopping the drugs
from pouring in president Trump has used
the illegal drug trade as justification
for the 18 billion dollar wall but a
former senior DHS official tells CBS
News that's not where the drugs are
coming from problem is the peel box in
America that gets the shipment through
our postal service straight from China
for nearly a year Senator Rob Portman
and a team of investigators have tracked
the deadly door-to-door delivery of
opioids it started with a simple Google
search which turned off retailers eager
to make a deal our fentanyl is very good
wrote one all must go until 1st of July
is a hot sale added another senator
Portman's team never actually bought any
drugs but in a separate probe they use
shipping and payment data to track 500
apparently successful deliveries of
opioids nationwide the deals totaled
nearly a quarter million dollars in
every case the country of origin was
China and the preferred method of
shipping the US Postal Service's Express
Mail service there's no requirement for
any electronic data in advance to be
able to tip off law enforcement the
Postal Service is supposed to work with
Customs and Border Protection
but Portman says they struggle with poor
coordination and volume so this is a
seizure room last fall we saw that
challenge at the nation's busiest mail
room inside JFK Airport
dogs and agents hands green only a
fraction of the packages I'm looking at
fentanyl fentanyl fentanyl again correct
Senate investigators want every package
headed to the US to include automated
data including the sender's name and
address 18 of the people who receive
drugs tracked by Portman's committee
face charges and seven died of an
overdose and when that 49 year old man
outside of Cleveland Ohio dies of an
overdose of fentanyl within a couple of
weeks of getting his delivery you
realize we're not doing our job
president Trump's opioid Commission has
also recommended advanced mail screening
but senator Portman's bill has yet to
come up for a vote in a statement the
postal service said it supports the goal
of increasing advanced electronic data
but has quote suggested thoughtful
modifications to the bill to make it
workable Norah alright Tony thank you